Si vous n'avez pas encore commandé, je trouve en général que les rigatonis avec la sauce épicée
vont très bien avec les maladies de l'intestin grèle.
(Rires)
Désolé -- c'est juste que j'ai l'impression que je devrais faire de la comédie stand-up ici sur cette scène à cause du décor.
Non, ce que je veux faire c'est vous ramener en 1854
à Londres pendant les prochaines minutes, et vous raconter l'histoire --
en bref -- de cette épidémie,
qui à plus d'un titre, je crois, a aidé à créer le monde dans lequel nous vivons aujourd'hui,
et en particulier le genre de ville dans lequel nous vivons aujourd'hui.
Cette période en 1854, au milieu du 19ème siècle,
dans l'histoire de Londres est incroyablement intéressante pour un certain nombre de raisons.
Mais je crois que la plus importante est que
Londres était une ville de 2,5 millions d'habitants,
la plus grande ville sur Terre à ce moment-là.
Mais c'était aussi la plus grande ville jamais construite.
Les Victoriens essayaient en quelque sorte d'y survivre
et simultanément d'inventer une nouvelle échelle de vie :
cette échelle de vie que nous appelons à présent la vie métropolitaine.
Et c'était de bien des manières, à ce moment du milieu des années 1850, un désastre complet.
C'était en gros une ville qui vivait avec un genre moderne de métropole industrielle
avec une infrastructure publique Elizabéthaine.
Donc les gens, par exemple, juste pour vous dégoûter pendant une seconde,
avaient des fosses d'aisance dans leur sous-sol. D'une profondeur de 30 à 60 cm.
Ils se contentaient d'y vider les seaux,
et d'espérer que ça disparaîtrait d'une façon ou d'une autre,
bien sûr ça ne disparaissait jamais vraiment .
Et tout ça, en gros, s'était accumulé au point
que la ville était incroyablement nauséabonde si on s'y promenait.
C'était une ville qui puait de façon étonnante. Pas seulement à cause des fosses d'aisance,
la simple quantité d'animaux dans la ville choquerait les gens.
Pas seulement des chevaux: les gens avaient des vaches dans leurs greniers qu'ils trayaient pour avoir du lait,
qu'ils hissaient là-haut et gardaient dans le grenier
jusqu'à ce que littéralement leur lait se tarisse et qu'elles meurent,
ils les traînaient alors jusqu'aux abattoirs au bout de la rue.
Donc, vous marchiez dans Londres à ce moment-là
et vous étiez accablé par cette puanteur.
Et finalement, un embryon de système de santé publique
a été convaincu que c'était l'odeur qui tuait tout le monde,
qui créait ces maladies
qui dépeuplaient la ville tous les 3 ou 4 ans.
Le choléra était vraiment le plus grand tueur de cette époque.
Il arriva à Londres en 1832, et tous les 4 ou 5 ans
une épidémie emportait 10 000, 20 000 personnes à Londres
et à travers tout le Royaume-Uni.
Les autorités ont fini par être convaincues que le problème venait de cette puanteur.
Il fallait s'en débarrasser.
Et donc, en fait, ils ont concocté les premières interventions
de santé publique dans le système de la ville,
l'une d'elles s'appelait la Loi contre les Nuisances,
par laquelle ils ont obligé tout le monde autant qu'ils le pouvaient
à vider leurs fosses d'aisances et à verser les déchets dans la rivière.
Parce que si on enlève ça des rues, ça sentira meilleur,
et -- oh, c'est vrai, nous buvons l'eau de la rivière.
Et ce qui a mené, en fait,
à augmenter les épidémies de choléra
parce que, comme nous le savons maintenant, le choléra est en fait dans l'eau.
C'est une maladie transmise par l'eau, pas quelque chose qui est dans l'air.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on respire ou qu'on inhale. C'est quelque chose qu'on ingère.
Ainsi un des moments fondateurs d'une sorte de santé publique au 19ème siècle
a en réalité empoisonné l'approvisionnement en eau de Londres d'une façon bien plus efficace
que n'importe quel bio-terroriste de nos jours aurait pu rêver de le faire.
Voilà donc l'état dans lequel était Londres en 1854,
et au milieu de tout ce carnage et de ces conditions choquantes,
et au milieu de toute cette confusion scientifique
au sujet de ce qui tuait vraiment les gens.
C'était un homme typique du 19ème siècle, bourré de talent et aux connaissances multidisciplinaires du nom de John Snow,
qui était médecin dans le quartier de Soho à Londres,
qui avait affirmé pendant 4 ou 5 ans
que le choléra était en fait une maladie transmise par l'eau,
et qui n'avait pratiquement convaincu personne.
Les autorités sanitaires avaient largement ignoré ce qu'il avait à dire.
Et il avait développé ses arguments dans un bon nombre de publications et il avait fait un bon nombre d'études,
mais rien n'avait vraiment été pris en compte.
Et en partie -- pour moi c'est ce qui est si intéressant dans cette histoire :
d'une certaine façon, c'est une excellente étude de cas sur la manière dont se produit un changement culturel.
Comment une bonne idée finit par l'emporter sur des idées bien pires.
Snow a travaillé longtemps avec cette grande perspicacité que tout le monde a ignorée.
Puis un jour, le 28 août 1854,
une petite fille de 5 mois dont nous ne connaissons pas le nom,
nous la connaissons seulement sous le nom de Bébé Lewis, a attrapé le choléra.
Elle avait le choléra au 40 Broad Street.
Vous ne le voyez pas vraiment sur cette carte, mais c'est la carte
qui devient le point central de la deuxième moitié de mon livre.
C'est au milieu de Soho, dans ce quartier ouvrier.
Cette petite fille tombe malade et il s'avère que la fosse d'aisance,
qu'ils ont toujours malgré la Loi contre les Nuisances,
jouxtait une pompe à eau extrêmement populaire,
le point d'eau local qui était bien connu pour être la meilleure eau de tout Soho,
où tous les résidents de Soho et des environs se rendaient.
Et donc cette petite fille sans le savoir a fini
par contaminer l'eau de cette pompe populaire,
et une des plus terribles épidémies dans l'histoire de l'Angleterre
a éclaté deux ou trois jours plus tard.
Littéralement, 10% du voisinage mourut en 7 jours,
et beaucoup plus seraient morts si les gens n'avaient pas fui
après le début de l'épidémie initiale.
C'était donc un événement incroyablement terrifiant.
On voyait des scènes où des familles entières mouraient
du choléra en 48 heures,
seules dans leurs appartements d'une seule pièce, dans leurs petits appartements.
Tout simplement une scène extraordinairement terrifiante.
Snow vivait près de là, a entendu parlé de l'épidémie,
et dans un acte de courage extraordinaire s'est rendu directement dans le ventre de la bête
parce qu'il pensait qu'une épidémie qui se concentrait
pouvait en fait éventuellement finir par convaincre les gens que,
en réalité, la vraie menace de choléra était dans l'approvisionnement en eau et pas dans l'air.
Il soupçonnait qu'une épidémie qui se concentrait
impliquait probablement une source unique.
Une seule chose où les gens allaient
parce que cette épidémie n'avait pas le lent cheminement traditionnel
des infections qu'on aurait pu attendre.
Et donc il s'y rendit directement et commença à interroger les gens.
Il a fini par s'adjoindre l'aide de cet autre personnage extraordinaire,
qui est en quelque sorte l'autre protagoniste du livre.
Cet homme, Henry Whitehead, qui était un pasteur local,
qui n'était pas du tout un homme de science, mais qui était incroyablement impliqué dans la société.
Il connaissait tout le monde dans le quartier,
et il a réussi à suivre, je parle de Whitehead,
de nombreux cas de personnes qui avaient bu de l'eau de la pompe,
ou qui n'avaient pas bu d'eau de la pompe.
Et finalement Snow a établi une carte de l'épidémie.
Il a découvert que de plus en plus de gens qui buvaient de l'eau de la pompe tombaient malades.
Les gens qui n'avaient pas bu de la pompe ne tombaient pas malades.
Et il a imaginé une représentation
sous la forme d'un tableau de statistiques des gens vivant dans les différents quartiers,
les gens qui n'avaient pas bu, vous voyez, les pourcentages de gens qui n'avaient pas bu,
mais finalement il en est arrivé à la conclusion
qu'il avait besoin de quelque chose que l'on pourrait visualiser.
Quelque chose qui prendrait d'une certaine manière une vision plus large
de toute cette activité qui s'était déroulée dans le quartier.
Et donc il créa cette carte,
ce qui en gros finit par représenter tous les morts du quartier
sous la forme de barres noires à chaque adresse.
Et vous pouvez voir sur cette carte, la pompe pile au centre
et vous pouvez voir qu'une des résidences au bout de la rue
comptait environ 15 morts.
La carte est en fait un petit peu plus grande.
En s'éloignant de plus en plus de la pompe,
les décès devenaient de moins en moins fréquents.
On peut donc comprendre qu'il y a quelque chose de toxique
qui émane de cette pompe, et ce d'un seul coup d'œil.
Donc, à l'aide de cette carte,
et avec l'aide d'une dose d'évangélisation
qu'il a dispensée pendant les quelques années qui ont suivi
ainsi que Whitehead, en fin de compte,
les autorités ont lentement commencé à se ranger à son avis.
Cela a pris plus longtemps que nous nous aimons à le penser dans cette histoire,
mais en 1866, quand l'épidémie suivante est survenue à Londres
les autorités avaient été convaincues - en partie à cause de cette histoire,
en partie à cause de cette carte -- que c'était en fait l'eau qui était le problème.
Ils avaient déjà commencé à construire les égouts à Londres,
et ils allèrent immédiatement vers cette épidémie
et ils dirent à tout le monde de se mettre à faire bouillir leur eau.
Ce fut la dernière fois que Londres a vécu une épidémie de choléra.
Donc une partie de cette histoire, je crois -- eh bien, c'est une histoire terrifiante,
c'est une histoire très sombre et c'est une histoire
qui continue dans de nombreuses villes en développement dans le monde.
C'est aussi une histoire qui est fondamentalement optimiste,
c'est-à-dire qu'il est possible de résoudre ces problèmes
si nous écoutons la raison, si nous écoutons la sagesse de ce genre de cartes,
si nous écoutons les gens comme Snow et Whitehead,
si nous écoutons les habitants qui comprennent
ce qui se passe dans ces situations.
Et ce à quoi ça a abouti, c'est de faire naître l'idée
que la vie métropolitaine à grande échelle était durable.
Quand les gens regardaient 10% de leurs voisins mourir
en l'espace de 7 jours,
il y a eu un large consensus selon lequel ça ne pouvait pas continuer comme ça,
que les gens n'étaient pas faits pour vivre dans des villes de 2,5 millions d'habitants.
Mais à cause de ce que Snow a fait, à cause de cette carte,
à cause de toute cette série de réformes
qui eurent lieu dans la foulée de cette carte,
nous tenons à présent pour acquis que les villes ont 10 millions d'habitants.
Des villes comme celle-ci sont en fait des choses durables.
Nous ne nous inquiétons pas de savoir si New York va s'effondrer sur elle-même
de la même façon que Rome l'a fait,
et n'être plus que 10% de sa taille dans 100 ou 200 ans.
Et donc, voilà d'une certaine façon l'héritage ultime de cette carte.
C'est une carte des morts qui a fini par créer un mode de vie complètement nouveau,
la vie dont nous jouissons ici aujourd'hui. Merci beaucoup.